Now it's time to look at our
usage data in Analytics.
Remember, to get to
the Analytics dashboard,
you go to analytics.google.com.
Log in, if you need to,
and choose your account.
And the Analytics dashboard
opens at the App Overview page.
But first,
I want to look at the realtime data.
So, go to Real Time and Overview.
Pause the video now while you go to
the Real Time Overview, right now.
When you go to a screen in your app,
a tracking hit is generated.
The Analytics service batches
up tracking requests and
sends them all together
at regular intervals.
I'll talk more about that soon.
The point here is that you might
need to wait a few minutes for
the data to start
showing up in your app.
The data's going to show up
while there are active users,
and then when nobody is using your app,
it's going to disappear.
Now let's look at the accumulated data.
To do that, go back to the App Overview.
Get that by clicking here, App Overview.
And the Overview page gives a summary
of all the data for your app.
Notice a default date range up here.
And you'll see that it ends in not
today's date, but yesterday's date.
So this is April the 6th,
today's actually April the 7th.
So, since we want to see
the data that we got for
today while we're testing,
we need to change the date range.
So you click on it, you choose
the start date and the end date.
And I recommend while you're
the only one using the app and
working through the course, just set
the date range to just be today.
So go to today, whichever that is.
For me, that's 7th of April.
Set the start date, and then the end
date will automatically be today,
because you can't go beyond today.
And you apply the date range.
And don't worry if you
don't see any data yet.
It might take a while for
the data to show up.
While we're waiting for
the data to arrive,
I'm going to talk a bit about sessions.